it was never easy to run a restaurant in
the united states around one in five
fail in their first year under the best
of circumstances
now covert shutdowns have completely
disrupted business forcing e3s to rely
on
takeout delivery and where they can
create new socially distanced
outdoor spaces but we still don't know
the full scope of the economic hit that
the restaurant industry has taken in
this country
how many will survive how many are
breaking the rules in order to survive
a survey from the national restaurant
association say uh says at least 17
of all restaurants over 100 000 in all
are currently closed whether
temporarily or permanently and with more
shutdowns looming
as cases surge and cold weather sets in
one restaurant owner told msnbc things
will only get worse
many of us were able to survive on
outdoor dining we were able to survive
on takeout and things like that
but the industry is is is holding on by
a thread and that thread is
fraying heavily
as congress inches ever so slowly
towards a relief deal
chefs and owners are demanding help now
a coalition of them are urging the
senate to pass the bipartisan
restaurants act which has already passed
in the house and would dedicate 120
billion dollars to helping restaurants
cover their pandemic losses among the
backers of that bill is marcus samuelson
he's an award-winning chef with
restaurants all over the world including
the famous red rooster
in harlem new york he's cooked for
people like barack obama and he's also a
best-selling author
during the pandemic he's been giving
back to the community teaming up with
the world central kitchen to feed those
facing hunger
and economic hardship and i'm happy to
say chef marcus samuelson joins me now
in fact he's out with a new book called
the rise black cooks and the soul of
american food
marcus thank you so much for coming on
the show new york city just shut down
indoor dining again as coveted cases are
spiking back up
obviously there's a difficult balance
between public health and allowing
businesses to survive
do you think our local our national
leaders are striking that balance
properly
well first of all thank you so much for
having me and hopefully i can come back
in
in a better time but this is i mean you
know yes
first of all restaurants is the word
restaurant means to restore your
community
right and um there are 11 million people
working in independent restaurants in
america
and 3 million of them are unemployed
right now
there's also 5 million people more there
are
butchers fishermen other people that
provide services for restaurant right so
that's basically the size of
holland or you know that's a lot of
people that are now
working in the independent restaurant
industry and when
uh congress looks at it they look at
restaurant in terms of
fast casual fast food chain restaurant
those are
very separate businesses some of them
can actually do even better during the
pandemic
there's nothing to do with independent
mom and pop
small businesses so first for us was
very
important to explain on narrative
explain a situation
for the politician because most of them
actually don't understand
what's the difference between a chain
restaurant and a mom and pop
independent restaurant and that's a very
important part
once we explain that this is not a
restaurant issue
this is an american issue that millions
of americans are now without jobs
and we need not more loans we actually
need
long-term solutions grants that
can be forgiven because the restaurant
industry
has on a good day you have 10 profit
margins that means that 90 cents to each
dollar
um goes back into the business that's on
a good day
let's say even five percent and in times
like this
so all the good years that you had you
have to save up for times like this that
it's a it's a new territory right most
restaurants are month to month
and does not have that type of capital
uh
built up and yeah listen
u.s government has for many many years
and decades
held big businesses but we as a
collective we
are a big business we are the largest
employee in this country
with the largest employees of minority
focus
go ahead yeah let me let me let me jump
in and ask you this a lot of senate
republicans will say
marcus we get it we did ppp small
business loans to help
small businesses why do we need this
restaurants act in addition
that that's a good question and it would
be great if they got it actually we got
the opportunity to fully uh
explain that right because
first of all restaurants didn't get
traditional bank loans to begin with so
we don't we're not funded on traditional
lending
we're actually very much like it is mom
and pop and small
investors right and we don't need more
loans the people fees are end of the day
they're loaned
that's not what the restaurant needs we
need long-term solutions
there are grants because we're going to
be in this for the long term even now
with the vaccine coming
that's great that's great for america
but that doesn't mean
that our restaurant business is going to
kick in think about in the northeast now
here in new york
boston no we you know northern part of
the states
it's winter now you can't eat outside
anymore
so uh you know maybe a restaurant does
30 40 take out but it's not going to be
enough
to survive so what are we gonna do four
five six
seven million people is going to go into
unemployment that's not good for anybody
and once restaurant goes all small
retail would go
that coffee shop that favorite bar that
uh small business so now we're talking
about another 15 20 million people
yeah and when we're talking about
millions of people we've seen a
staggering increase also marcus in food
insecurity
uh during this pandemic you and your
restaurant red rooster have been able
to give back to people in need not just
in harlem where your restaurant is but
also places i believe like newark new
jersey you wrote recently in the wall
street journal
what it means to be a part of and in
service to your community
has radically changed during this
pandemic right now
in the pandemic what does giving back
mean to you
well you know first of all we're part of
a larger community
and my friend jose andres had started
world center kitchen
uh way before this and they had the
experience to serve
in in when there were situations like
this but in newark for example it was
another partnership with newark working
kitchen and
dawn cats so uh we were we said right
away how can we help out
uh in newark collectively we served 500
000 meals over the last six
months with about 30 restaurants or so
it helped the neediest
it helped the restaurant community and
we served also
uh first responders in harlem i read
rooster we served about 220 000 meals
from one restaurant from our restaurant
together with world central kitchen so
it's about helping the neediest creating
job saving jobs for the industry and
also first responders when we can do
that
we help everybody the businesses stays
alive
the first responders and the neediest
get get uh
well-deserved meals
yes 100 agree with you and it's amazing
what you're doing
i have to ask you were born in ethiopia
grew up in sweden and now you're an
american citizen
uh what are the last four years of trump
been like for you do you think
things may change now that he's leaving
or is the anti-immigrant the xenophobic
the racist sentiments that he's
unleashed amplified
is that going to be with us for many
years to come do you think
well i you know the good thing is with
democracy you know sometimes you win
sometimes you lose
and um i look forward to the biden
harris uh
era uh it's clear uh on so many levels
on the uh three pandemics that we have
in this country our very
environmental crisis right you see it
every year we get hotter and hotter and
um the race uh pandemic of race and
and culture that we have to create a
much more equitable table
and of course the pandemic of kobe these
were all three things that
my opinion and my point of view on this
stands vastly different than
than the outgoing um uh
trump and pence right so but the good
thing is that we can move forward and
reality is that you know
race and cultural identity environmental
these were issues that were here
way before trump and it got highlighted
and they
they felt they had to partner with him
now we gotta look forward
we have to change this narrative it's
important not just for america it's
important for the message that america
sends out for the world
so this has impact in europe you know i
grew up in sweden
uh europe is also extremely divided so i
i look forward to
for us to get back into paris agreement
i look forward to us to be a great
partner out there in the world
uh but you know what for me right now in
my community for the next 90 days
it's all about saving small businesses
in america our restaurant community
needs
real help from the government from the
federal government
and from the local government that's the
only way millions of restaurant workers
gonna be able
to save their jobs
well i do hope congress i do hope the
white house are listening to people like
yourself and jose andres who was also on
the show making
a similar message you guys are doing
great work we appreciate your great work
keep doing what you're doing
congratulations
on your new book and i do hope you can
come back under better circumstances we
will have you back on the show i hope
uh chef marcus samuelson thank you so
much for your time and for your passion
hi i'm mehdi hussain thanks for checking
out our channel on youtube you can see
more of the mehdi hassan show
by clicking on any of the videos on this
screen and make sure you subscribe below
to stay up to date
on the day's biggest stories thank you
for watching